[Music]
on this Saturday night dozens of
vulnerable people died in Quebec it's a
dire situation now a criminal
investigation is being launched into a
care home Canada's political parties
come together to keep the paychecks
coming plus the grim milestone in the
United States the hot spot for Cova 19
and the greater danger of the new
coronavirus in developing nations
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with a disturbing story out
of Quebec at least 31 residents from a
private care home in Montreal have died
in the last month five were confirmed
with kovat 19 today premier Francois
logo ordered a criminal investigation
the owner of this residence refused to
give us access to the file of the
patients and it's only last night at 8 8
p.m. that we learned that the number
that since March 13 was 31 the premier
says he believes it's a case of gross
negligence as Dan Specter reports
residents appear to have endured
unthinkable conditions in the home a
body is removed from Haren residents in
Dorval Quebec on Saturday one of more
than two dozen people to die inside the
private seniors residence since March
13th our sympathies through tears the
head of the West Island Health Authority
gives her condolences to the families
who had entrusted the residents to take
care of their loved ones as she tried to
explain how things went so wrong they
were struggling to keep their ratios of
staff to residents McVeigh said on March
29th it became clear the situation at
Haren was critical Peter Wieland's
mother was among those living in dire
conditions he says one day staff told
her they didn't have enough time to
change her diaper and clean up her burst
urine bag the urine stayed on the floor
for another 12 hours
health officials claim their offers to
help the residents were met with little
collaboration we had two formal notices
two formal legal notices asking for them
to give us information about the
residence this just sent people to help
on March 29th including retired nurse
Loredana male so we went from room to
room and every room the stench of urine
and feces could have killed the horse
after health officials stepped in gail
Steinberg says she could not reach her
102 year old father I can't help but
wonder if if the staff is just deserted
the placement her
there had been tested for kovat 19 he
died on April 6th before the results
came back more important to me today is
I would like to know if he was one of
those patients who was neglected most
recent promise they made toys they broke
within an hour police officers were
outside the residence all day it's now
being investigated for criminal
negligence it's health officials claim
things are better now authorities
promise to call each and every family of
deceased residents to give them an
explanation Dan Specter Global News
Dorval Quebec BC Alberta and Ontario are
also dealing with Cova 19 outbreaks in
long-term care homes today the federal
government announced it's bringing in
new measures to protect care home
residents and workers Morgan Campbell
has the latest on those efforts with
more than 100 nursing homes in Ontario
reporting cases of kovat 19 government
officials are looking to ensure
frontline workers have the equipment
they need to protect themselves these
are incredibly horrific reports that
we've all been seeing access to
equipment and Retraining has been an
area of contention Global News began
questioning officials about training
after observing healthcare employees
wearing PPE outside this Bobcaygeon
nursing home Pine Crest nursing home is
ground zero for a major outbreak that
has spread among staff and residents
leaving at least 30 seniors dead through
its Facebook page the president of the
Ontario personal support workers
Association said that her members had
training but went on to raise concerns
that the speed at which the viruses hit
made it difficult to bring staff up to
speed I don't know if any entity that
can have training out that fast when
you're dealing with mass hysteria and
war zones on the frontline the Ontario
chief medical officer has stated it's up
to each facility to offer proper
training the administrator at Pine Crest
nursing home says all staff received
this training on how to use the
equipment our home has been fully
stocked with PPE
from day one but Mary Karr did not
answer questions from Global News as to
why staff or volunteers appeared to
where the equipment's outside Tim Delta
is with UFCW
a union that represents more than 2000
long-term care home employees in Ontario
he says PSWs deserve higher pay
full-time jobs and more supports on the
frontlines these are things that we
strongly believe that the provincial
government could implement quickly and
that would be a real benefit the
provinces Minister of Health won't
commit to higher wages but are looking
into creating full-time jobs that's
going to be another key method of
keeping kovat 19 out of long-term care
homes but advocates want more done and
they want it done now they're sitting in
their cars before they go into long-term
care they're crying they're scared to
bring it back to their loved ones at
home
Morgan Campbell Global News the Senate
has approved the federal government's
emergency wage subsidy bill
it's a 73 billion dollar plan to allow
employers impacted by the Cova 19 crisis
to keep people on the payroll or rehire
those who've been laid off the prime
minister says the measure will provide
relief in the short term the government
will pay them up to 75 percent of their
of their salary so that when this is
through Canadians will still have
connection to those jobs and our economy
can get going again
as Mike Lakota reports even though
politicians from all political stripes
support the subsidy there are concerns
the government's economic boost won't
help everyone who needs it not your
typical Saturday sights but there's
nothing typical about a weekend sitting
of the House of Commons and that was
underscored in the Prime Minister's
speech to Parliament and Canadians in a
modern-day call to arms against an
invisible enemy instead the front line
is everywhere in our homes in our
hospitals and care centers in our
grocery stores and pharmacies while
asking all Canadians to do their part by
staying apart political parties came
together Nago
shading unanimous consent on the wage
subsidy legislation the measure will see
the federal government pay 75% of
employees wages to help keep them on
company payrolls a week ago we said this
would take three to six weeks obviously
now that's two to five weeks and we're
aspiring to do that as rapidly as
possible I'm assured that we will be
closer to the short end of that time a
quick turnaround considering this kind
of legislation normally takes months to
draft but not quick enough for some
business owners there they're really
worried about the additional two to five
weeks before they actually get money in
their hands because they are trying as
best they can to meet their payroll
requirements but that's becoming
increasingly challenging as their income
is trickle has trickled down to zero
dan Kelly says with about 80% of small
and medium-sized businesses already shut
down this public health crisis is
quickly becoming a mental health crisis
it's gotten so bad that we're starting
to get calls from business owners that
are considering taking their own lives
now it's why the NDP believes the
candidate emergency relief benefit
should be paid to every Canadian right
now while the Conservatives are pushing
for more oversight of the government
while it rushes historic economic
measures of the door you very much
believe that in-person accountability
sessions in the House of Commons will
lead to better results for Canadians a
government house leader Pablo Rodriguez
says committees are already meeting via
teleconference and the speaker is
looking at a virtual version of
Parliament but he points out reopening
the Commons would mean support and
security staff would also have to come
to work all at a time when they're
telling Canadians the best way to fight
the pandemic is to stay home robin
michael--ah couture in ottawa thanks
Mike the economic shock from Cova 19 is
huge right across Canada businesses are
closed and nobody knows when they'll be
back up and running if at all our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson joins us
now Mercedes it's very likely that so
many businesses won't be able to weather
the pandemic storm Robin the
government's promised aid for businesses
is being welcomed but there's concern it
could be coming too late
their complaints from business groups
the government took the time to make
some fixes including making more
businesses eligible and lowering the
threshold for how much income businesses
would have to have lost in order to
qualify this week on the West block i
sat down with Perrin bt who is a former
health minister with a head for business
as the president and CEO of the Canadian
Chamber of Commerce I asked him how many
Canadian businesses will succumb to the
economic freeze we're currently in
nobody can quantify it with any
precision but we were clearly talking
about tens of thousands of businesses
many of which have gone dark and won't
reopen as a consequence the average
small business has perhaps three weeks
of revenues that it can function with
cash in the bag to be able to function
without more money coming in we're now
into going into the fifth week of
lockdown and we're talking about a
program that will take some weeks yet
before businesses are able to find the
money from that that means that many of
them will simply run out of cash in the
mean time that people their employees
will lose their jobs and the
government's will lose the tax revenue
and people have invested all their
savings and their dreams and building a
business will have lost those as well
and that's why this is a human tragedy
on so many different levels we'll also
talk about whether mr. Bede thinks there
should be a bailout for big oil how to
balance protecting health with a
functioning economy and whether it's
time to invoke the emergencies act Robin
all right thanks Mercedes and you can
watch the West block tomorrow morning
right here on global here's where the
number of cases stand in Canada tonight
there are more than 23,000 confirmed
cases and more than 650 people have died
Quebec has been hit the hardest where
more than eleven and a half thousand
people have tested positive and more
than 240 people have died in that
province but there is some hope more
than six thousand Canadians have
recovered from the virus they were
growing calls for the federal government
to crack down on foreign workers coming
from Mexico to begin seasonal farm work
without being told to quarantine or
being tested for Cova 19 when they
we believe we affirm clearly that it is
the responsibility of the Canadian
government when they have somebody
released from the airport to make sure
that those workers which once again I
welcome I've been through a test and
true required quarantine about 60,000
foreigners arrived in Canada each year
to work on farms despite closing the
border to international travel the
federal government says these workers
can continue to come here but that
farmers are responsible for enforcing
strict measures to stop the spread of
kovat 19 Alberta premier Jason Kenney
says his province is making good
progress in the fight against kovat 19
and that means Alberta has an excess of
masks personal protective equipment and
ventilators so he's offering up some of
the surplus to help other provinces in
need including Quebec Ontario and BC I
for one as an Albertan and as a Canadian
could not in conscience watch us the
stockpile massive amounts of surplus
equipment while we see many of our
fellow Canadians in some provinces
within days of running out of some of
these supplies and Air Canada says it is
transforming three of its Boeing triple7
so the planes can transport medical
supplies across Canada by removing 422
seats the company will double its cargo
capacity the first aircraft has hit the
skies the two other planes will be in
service within days coming up the Cova
19 crisis gets worse in the United
States with a new record
let's take a look at the global pandemic
numbers now there are more than 1.7
million cases of Coppa 19 around the
world the u.s. is reporting more than
20,000 deaths surpassing Italy as the
country with the most fatalities today
alone the u.s. recorded more than 1700 s
and in each state the local governments
are struggling with making decisions
about schools reopening and church
services on this holy weekend Jennifer
Johnson reports as America becomes the
world's greatest victim of kovat 19
government officials continue to plead
with citizens to stay home but on this
holy weekend there's a state-by-state
debate over allowing people to attend
religious services at least eight states
are allowing people to congregate Easter
Sunday including Florida whose governor
continues to preach social distancing
and we said stay away from crowds stay
home as much as you can be careful out
there
in other states Church parking lots will
be patrolled and license plates recorded
to enforce 14 day quarantines but in
most cities and towns pews will be empty
the faithful looking for hope through
online services be patient
endure the Reverend Timothy Cole will
speak to his congregation through video
after kovat 19 put him in intensive care
for 21 days and forced nearly 400 of his
parishioners to self isolate if anyone
was to come now to church and get the
virus and die then I think we would all
feel really really president Donald
Trump backed off from his earlier hope
of filling up Easter Sunday churches now
he's focused on slowly reopening
businesses and plans to meet with a new
task force studying that next week the
World Health Organization and White
House coronavirus doctors are warning if
lockdown measures are lifted too early
infection rates could soar again is this
choice but I certainly will continue as
I've always had to give my honest
assessment of the scientific and data
that is really the evidence that I based
my judgments on but local leaders are
really in control of what will reopen
and what will stay closed New York
City's mayor has decided to suspend the
rest of the school year
at America's largest district it's
literally a painful decision to close
our schools because we feared at that
moment that we would not be able to
bring them back schools are expected to
reopen in September lawmakers and
educators have learned their lesson on
just how dangerous Kovan 19 can be
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
still ahead the hard lessons Canadians
are learning about savings with the
Kovach crisis it's an incredibly
stressful time for so many Canadians who
found themselves out of work or without
a paycheck financial advisors generally
encourage people to save three to six
months of their salary in an emergency
fund but as David akin reports that's
not how most Canadians live for most of
the last decade
Canadians spent what they earned new TVs
new cars new homes and if Canadians
earnings were not enough canadians
borrowed and why not interest rates have
been stuck at generational lows job
growth had been strong so strong that
unemployment has also touched
generational lows the kovat 19 crisis
turned all of that upside down the issue
for a lot of Canadians is that they have
no savings they live paycheck to
paycheck they might have a bit of money
in the account that'll get them to the
end of the month but if they're off work
for a month or two they're in serious
financial difficulty and that has put
into stark relief another number that
has hovered near generational lows the
National household savings rate for the
last decade Canadians have barely saved
3 and a half cents of every dollar of
disposable income 3 and a half cents to
the dollar the end result just one in
every three Canadians or 31% say they
have less than a week of savings or no
savings at all to rely on that's
according to a poll by Ipsos provided
exclusively to global news just under 1
in 4 or 23% have two to four weeks of
savings well another 1 in 5 or 20
percent say they have between 5 and 13
weeks of savings to draw on that partly
explains why the federal government
focus has been on replacing income
rather than protecting savings income
was almost Canadians had most of the
folks that are going to be laid off are
not making $100,000 a year $150,000 a
year and have a big savings account most
of them are making twelve fourteen
fifteen dollars an hour they have no
savings they live paycheck to paycheck
the great irony is that Canadians cannot
now afford to be a nation of savers
Canadians have to be a nation of
spenders Canadians need to spend on a
meal at a local restaurant some new
clothing at a favorite retailer spend on
a new home and all the furnishings in it
for a quick and speedy recovery
Canadians have to spend and not save
David Aitken Global News Ottawa as we
keep you informed on Cova 19 Donna
Friesen will be hosting a special
program on Sunday evenings it's called
coronavirus the new reality and it
starts tomorrow at 7 p.m.
up next the devastation facing
developing nations as they prepare for
the pandemic most of helping nations are
already in crisis with weak economies
fragile healthcare systems and food
scarcity as Redman Shannon reports kovat
19 will likely cause even more death and
destruction in this part of the world in
developing nations like Uganda covered
19 threatens to be even more devastating
than it has been in Italy Spain or New
York weak health care systems poor
sanitation and cramped living conditions
could all contribute to a higher death
toll and with much of the planet on
lockdown these nations don't have the
financial resources to support those
unable to work the UN says more than
half of the world has no access to
income support food
money I think everybody has to pray I'd
rather die from disease than from hunger
says this man in India's capital New
Delhi articulating the brutal choice
that so many are facing the World Food
Programme says the crisis will likely
worsen the situation in Africa's Sahel
region drought and violence there have
already put millions more at risk of
hunger this year so a major challenge
now although all the area or the routes
are blocked and as the axis are really
limited and and we are trying to prepare
ourselves to help to avoid the karana
spread for medics preparing for kovat
19:00 the challenges and dangers are
even greater than in the West we can
doctor Mamadou bowel day works in an
infectious disease unit in Sierra Leone
he says even in normal circumstances
basic equipment is in short supply
the country has just a handful of
ventilators
however Sierra Leone does have the
advantage of lessons learned from the
2014 Ebola outbreak position but many
developing countries do not have that
traumatic memory and as the virus takes
hold the only warnings they have are the
grim stories currently unfolding in the
West Redman Shannon Global News London
and that's Kabul national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill tonight we leave
you with an Olympian effort to help
health care workers a Premier of Ontario
hockey player turned medical student
Hayley Wiccan Heiser scored this
FaceTime with actor Ryan Reynolds as the
in Ontario Premier Doug Ford assisted
her PPE drive in Toronto volunteers used
hockey sticks to support distancing
measures as they collected thousands of
supplies for
line workers another sign of communities
coming together good night
you